Speaker 1: Yesterday I told you about
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham
threatening riots if Donald Trump is indicted.
Infowars conspiracy theorist Alex Jones,
who, by the way, really doesn't like me.
Speaker 2: Thank your lucky stars
every day. You're not Dave David Pakman.
Speaker 1: I know he doesn't like me. Alex Jones
is now joining in with MAGA World in predicting
violence. Now, as always, his predictions
are more specific. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: The next 71 days, we're going to see
some very violent fireworks. I would predict.
Racially motivated mass shootings, bombings,
poisonings.
Speaker 1: We're
going to see poisonings and bombings, he says.
Speaker 2: Attacks on power supplies being blamed
on the right wing. They intend to bring in
a full dictatorship in the next 71 days.
Speaker 1: Who will be the dictators?
Speaker 2: And we are all strapped
to this thing. This is such a dangerous
time. And I would advise the globalist.
There are mid-level that think they're
about to have a leftist revolution.
Speaker 1: I like that mid-level
globalists. If you're a high level globalist
or a low level globalist, you don't have
to worry globalist, internationalist,
Trotskyites socialists. Unlike Obama, Trudeau,
Macron, and the rest of the Zio Bush bitch.
Yeah. All right, last few seconds.
Speaker 2: Globalist. Don't actually
plan at the higher levels now that they
plan on having a civil war that brings
down America. And you'll be the fall guy.
Speaker 1: Right. Very, very scary stuff. Now,
I do wonder if there's a donation maybe of 29, 99
to Alex Jones. That might help stop the globalist.
I don't know. Is it more upsetting, honestly?
Is it more upsetting that Alex Jones says
this stuff? Or is it more upsetting that
some people believe it? Or is it more upsetting
that some people believe it so much that then
they donate money as a result? Which of
those three things is the most disturbing?
And this is very similar to yesterday's segment
on Lindsey Graham. It sounds to me like Alex Jones
is predicting that Trumpists are going to do
all these things, but he's incentivized to make
it look like they're not really Trumpists
if they do it. Because remember, he said
There's going to be bombings and there's going to
be poisonings and there's going to be attacks on
our water supplies, you know, different. What did
he say? Power sources. And it's going to be blamed
on the right. He already is preemptively, you
know, he just got dinged almost 50 million
for lies related to supposed false flags. And
he's already out there doing his false flag dog
and pony show. Again, it's quite a wild situation.
But there's Alex Jones, Joy, Alex Jones joining in